- No, but can you tell us
anything about the final season?
Everybody, this show is such a huge show.
People are just
- Yeah.
- They're probably very sad.
- I am very sad.
- I know.
- We're all very sad.
- Isn't that weird that
you've been around people
for that long and then all of a sudden
you're not gonna see them everyday?
I don't mean to make you
cry about it or anything.
- Yeah, you know, I'm an emotional girl.
- I am too.
- It's like she really
trying to well these up.
- No, no.
- Honestly, every day everyone's like,
"Chrissy, you okay?"
I'm like, don't ask me if I'm okay.
Are we all okay?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's emotional.
You spend six years of your life
with people who've changed your life
and stories that have
changed other people's lives.
So yeah, I'm emotional,
but also this season
is going to be incredible.
And you know,
I don't know if anybody has
seen the finale of season five.
- Yes
- Okay, some people have,
and if you haven't, closed your ears,
- Spoiler alert
- Spoiler alert, we will
get to see how Toby and Kate
sort of unravel.
- Okay
- And then of course we're
following Rebecca storyline
and her Alzheimer's and it's
going to be very emotional
and, and very wonderful and
beautiful and, you know.
- Seems nice to have wine
with this, all I'm saying
- That's Right, that's
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
- It's a nice compliment.
It's a nice compliment.
I heard that you're practicing accents.
- Oh, never hold the glass.
- Oh, I don't care!
I'm the girl that like
goes to all the tastes,
you know, the testing thing.
And they're like, never do this.
I'm like sure, okay.